tu leur parles toujours été amis c'est
compliqué la première fois qu'on a été
réunie on était différent
[Musique]
papier dit anthony lc marta et bethany
le grand-père de spencer a chanté sa
rolls
désolé je m'incruste hutin christ pas
contrairement à nous mais ils ont au
coeur bat vous auriez pourvu spencer je
crois qu'il y est retournée faut aller
le chercher
berthon d'elle mais ça va pas on a même
parfois sinon ça va te coûter cette
spéciale c'est quoi ce bruit
spezza quoi qu'êtes vous au curé vous
êtes le grand père de spens est-ce qu'on
est en floride
et vous les lots walker est ce que je
suis mort est réincarné en un petit
scout musclé est ce qu'on est mort
bethany non non non fring je suis le
petit vieux tout rond au non c'est pas
vrai mais de rhumatismes c'est chouette
regarde moi si cuisse way sacré cuit
regarde moi c'est qui se voit qu'on a un
gros problème je l'applaudis à ça je
suis pas dedans je passe dedans
bienvenue dans tout manger
cette aventure est encore plus difficile
et souvenez-vous la pire jumanji d'entre
vous marquez il question importante
c'est qui je m'engage et ses fils de
barrage
on va mourir c'est déjà fait est-ce
qu'on est en enfer je le savais
il faut que vous ayez des yeux derrière
tout ça perd lot
[Musique]
bon sang c'est quoi ces attributs de nos
personnages puissants regarde tomber un
débile que tu peux avoir quoi tu fais
une crise cardiaque respire mais aller
il ya tout le côté gauche en vrac est
dit